>> Hello everyone, my name is
Anne Savage and I work at the,
in the Education Department
at the Library of Congress.
We are thrilled to welcome you to the second
annual Online Conference for Educators.
Our session today, Library
of Congress 101 for Teachers
and now I would like to introduce our speaker.
Our speaker for this evening is Cheryl Lederle.
She has worked as an Educational
Resources Specialist at the Library
of Congress since December of 2003.
In that role, she has advanced
the library's educational mission
by providing professional development
both in person and via webinar.
She's also played a significant role in
shaping the library's online repository
of classroom materials and resources
for teachers at loc.gov/teachers,
and she continues to contribute to
the development of those materials.
Cheryl has 15 years experience teaching English
at both the high school and
community college levels.
Welcome, Cheryl.
>> Thanks Ann, and welcome to all of
you who I expect have taught a full day,
and I appreciate that you are
choosing to spend your evening with us.
I want to explore what the Library of Congress
has for teachers, looking particularly
at lesson plans and primary source sets,
webinars and professional
development opportunities.
And then I want to spend just a little bit
of time introducing you to what's behind all
of these teacher materials and we'll
explore very briefly ways to tap
into those vast library collections
to find even more.
What I've put up on screen now is Capitol Hill
and you can see the Capitol
there in the foreground.
And behind it and just to the right on
the widescreen there's a domed building.
That's the very beautiful Thomas
Jefferson building completed in 1897.
There are two other buildings on Capitol
Hill in addition to the Jefferson building
that comprise the library on Capitol Hill.
We also have some off-site storage.
That gives you a little bit of
context for where I'm coming from.
I've also put some statistics on the
screen just because I like the numbers.
The library has more than 160 million items.
There are more than 830 miles of book shelves.
The library receives, through
copyright deposit and other means,
approximately 15,000 items a day.
And of those it adds to the
collections about 12,000 items a day.
That's a big number for any of you, but
I saw several of you were librarians.
Just think for a minute about
the task of processing
up to 12 million-- excuse
me-- 12,000 items a day.
We'd love to have you visit us on Capitol
Hill, but until that time you can visit us
from wherever you have a sturdy internet
connection using this access point,
the library's website, loc.gov.
Feel free to explore these links or sit
back and relax and make notes for yourself
about what you want to come back to.
Again this is the home page,
access to all of the collections.
My home and Anne's at the library are the
Especially for Teachers section and I'm going
to spend the first part of our time together--
my professional life is dedicated
to making it easier for you to find
and use those online collections.
And several of you are saying you
have various levels of experience.
I'm glad that some of you have,
are feeling comfortable with it.
Even if you are a very comfortable user
I'm going to guess that time is always
in short supply for a busy teacher.
That was my experience teaching.
So I'm going to hit some highlights
of shortcuts that you might take.
And the first one highlighted
in the pink box just
under the classroom materials black bar is the
Teaching with the Library of Congress blog.
We've been blogging for several years now.
In addition to what we publish a couple of
times a week, it's also keyword searchable
so that you can go back and explore the archive.
And I have search results using
the term Informational Text.
As a former English teacher I get
pretty excited about informational text.
And so I like that as my search result.
But you can search by other things,
topics, grade levels, and so forth.
So I would commend this to you.
If you'd like to hear from us on a
regular basis, subscribe to the blog.
You can see at the top, to the right
there's an orange subscribe link
and that would have this sent to
your inbox when we publish it.
Back to the teacher's home page to orient you.
I'm going to visit next Classroom
Materials and I'm not going
to spend too much time clicking
around any of these pages.
What I'm hoping to do is alert you to the
possibility that they exist and invite you
to come back and explore on your own.
So the classroom materials page, the pink
box now is around one of my favorite features
and that is it's searchable by standards.
If you can squint a little, you can see that the
radio buttons allow you to search by common core
or state content or a selection
of national organizations.
And clicking into common core or state content
gives you the option to then identify your state
since different states apply
those standards differently.
The first stop on our tour of classroom
materials is primary source sets.
And that's just what they sound like.
They're sets of primary sources.
And we started developing those
when in conversation with teachers
about using the lesson plans that we've
been publishing for quite a number
of years we realized that teachers are
taking apart the lesson plans looking
for primary sources of use
and then for teaching ideas
and this sounded very familiar
from my days as a teacher.
I didn't teach somebody else's lesson
plan but I loved to mine their ideas.
And so we put the primary source sets together.
It's 18 primary sources on a particular theme or
topic and there are more than 30 of these now.
And then each one we wrap in a teacher's guide--
looks about like this, this is the top of it--
with a brief historical background
about the theme or topic.
And then in additional also
teaching ideas for it.
Each primary source set also links to
the teacher's guides an analysis tool.
And several of the presentations during the
online conference have made reference to this.
The analysis tool looks pretty simple
because the design of it is pretty simple.
It is three columns-- observe,
reflect, and question.
And then an invitation for
students to think about what they'd
like to investigate to learn more about.
The process itself is way less simple and that's
reflected in the upper right corner of this,
the circular arrow that says
observe, reflect, and question.
And we recognize that it is not at all
a linear process but flat paper sort
of limits our ability to represent that.
So we've done what we can.
You'll notice if you look,
that it's available by,
for different formats and I've pulled that up.
Choosing a format changes the question set.
You can see there's a red circle around
select the format of your primary source,
and then another red circle around a question.
Clicking on that question
will bring up a question.
icon will bring up a question.
And you can customize that by format or
just as questions that are generally useful
for helping students dig deeper into looking
at and thinking about primary sources.
Here's a sample.
This is a set from the more general ones.
There are 10 format specific
teacher guides in addition to this.
At the bottom of the teacher's guide you can see
that there are some follow up activity ideas--
beginning, intermediate, and advanced.
And I think of those levels as not only the
complexity for the student but the complexity
for the teacher to implement them.
And generally speaking, the
beginning ones are a very easy lift
on the teacher and still give rich information.
I use a lot of beginning ones when I
do professional development programs.
So there certainly can still lead to some
rich and deep thinking and information.
A selection of the primary
source sets are also available
as free e-books through the iTunes store.
Those have the same content
from the primary source sets
but the technology allows
us to embed some tools.
So if you have iPads available in
your school you might check these out.
If you don't you can still get all the same
content through those primary source sets.
I return to the classroom materials page-- I'm
not going to take time to tour the lesson plans
because your teachers and you all
know what a lesson plan looks like.
I would invite you to explore those.
It's a great way to find some ideas and a
shortcut for finding primary sources as well
if you find a lesson plan
on something you teach.
I do want to take a look at a
couple of the presentations.
We have a fair selection of them and
it struck me as timely to feature
for you today elections the American way.
These feature primary sources from the library's
collection-- collections I should say--
but also give a little more context and history.
So if you're-- if you or your students want
to do a little bit of reading on the process
or issues from past presidential
elections or the right to vote,
this would be for example a resource for that.
Back to the teacher's home page, I'd
like to look at professional development.
Right now you're all participating in
an example of professional development
that we offer for distance learning.
And there is a link on the
professional development subpage.
It's toward the bottom of the
screen boxed in pink for webinars.
We have quite a number of
these that we've been doing,
and you may be wondering why is Cheryl
telling me this about past events?
Well you can see looking at this grid that we
record most of them and make them available
after the fact just as we'll be recording
and making available the 15 hours of content
from this online conference,
we have past events.
We also do on-site workshops including a
week-long summer teacher institute here
at the library.
If you're interested in that, the best way--
the best way to find out about that is to
subscribe to the blog and watch for it.
We usually publicize the application
sometime around December-ish.
December, early January.
And the first notice of that will go out through
the blog and our other social media channels.
Back to the homepage for
the Library of Congress.
I want to talk just a little bit about
how to find your way around that.
Many of you said you have some comfort with
searching on the library so I'm going to guess
that if that's true you've met this
homepage search bar and this searches most
of the library's online collections.
There are two sections that are not included
and I'll talk about those in just a little bit.
But this searches more than 30 million files.
You can narrow your search by format, if you
know for example that you want a map to fill
in something in your lesson plan
or you're working with learners
who respond particularly
well to visual materials--
maps or photos, prints, or
drawings-- you can search by format.
Once you get a search result you can
also search by, narrow your search
by other facets that'll look very familiar.
If you're not sure what I'm
talking about, you'll recognize it.
You can narrow it by date
range for example in addition
to format once you get to that results page.
And so I'd encourage you to explore
that and find your way around.
I will note that a relatively recent--
as in the last five, six years--
is that any of those search results
that you narrow can be shared as links.
So if you need-- if you need to support your
students by identifying a body of possibilities
for them that they then dig around in,
you can share those search results.
I want to dig now into two sections that
are not covered in that homepage search.
The first is historic American
newspapers Chronicling America.
How many of you have used Chronicling America?
And if you've used it and want to talk a
little bit about what your experience has been,
I think it's very valuable
for people to hear from those
of you who are in the field practicing.
I know theoretically what it looks like with
students, but my audience now is adults.
I'm going to continue showing
you how to get to this.
You can click through from the library site
or directly from that link that Anne put in.
It's also a good search term,
Chronicling America.
Chronicling America is a website that
provides free public access to more
than 11 million pages of
historic U.S. newspapers.
I'm going to hit some highlights but
if you want to go deeper into this,
several of the folks here today have
mentioned that they watched the earlier session
and that'll be available in the recording.
Vicki, yes, it can be difficult to read
and hone in on what they want to need.
Also very exciting.
The earlier session did give a little bit
of conversation about that and we also,
last year's online conference-- last year's
online conference had a whole session
and our last year's teacher in
residence had a passion for working
with newspapers and joined that conversation.
So you might look at that if
you're looking for even more tips.
The easiest way to get into Chronicling
America is to do a keyword search.
It can however yield a daunting
number of possibilities.
This is the results from the word prohibition.
You'll notice if you haven't used this you might
be a little surprised to see all the pink boxes.
You can see in some of the
headlines, those pink boxes are
around the search term--
in this case, prohibition.
Janelle it is-- let me go back a
couple of slides and bring Janelle up.
I will also say that it being a
website, expect that it will change.
So I'm certainly happy to show
you the path from the homepage.
You're probably better off if
you remember the name of it
so that you can search for it and find it.
But from the homepage, click
into historic newspapers and then
from historic newspapers we have
several different collections.
Click into Chronicling America
and we're back to the search term.
If your students or you are
looking for a real great shortcut--
I'm going to guess that some of you don't
know this-- go to the recommended topics page.
These are guides to topics, more than
250 of them, put together by experts
from the newspaper division that provides
background information for well-known
and lesser known events with important
dates, search strategies and sample articles.
And I'm going to go-- I'm going
to play with the drawing arrow
and point out to you where I found this.
So from Chronicling America homepage,
it's right there in the left nav
and it's called recommended topics.
This map shows the scope of Chronicling America.
It's actively adding new states every year
and recently added several new partners.
You can see that it now covers
most of the United States.
The states in grey have not applied
or received a grant from the NEH
but they are actively working on that.
I'm going to pause.
Any questions about Chronicling America?
Anything you want me to go
back to before I move forward?
As I say, I'm hitting the highlights very
quickly knowing that we have a whole session
on Chronicling America and
that you can view the recording
at your leisure and explore at your leisure.
Is it common not to find
what you're looking for?
Man, that's a tough question, Janelle.
It's not uncommon because for one thing
you're searching in historical collections.
And they night not use the language that you're
accustomed to which is one of the reasons
that those suggested search strategies
in the topics are a real goldmine.
It is keyword searchable which is a huge boon,
but that's a lot of words for it to search.
The advanced search strategies give you a
little more control over how you approach it.
I will say it's pretty common
that you need to take a couple
of different approaches to
find what you're looking for.
And again, I'm just going to sound like
I'm advertising for that other session.
She went through a lot of those
more detailed search tips and ideas.
I would encourage you to take
different approaches and yes, Jennifer,
you're absolutely right, it's much
easier than scanning through microfiche
where you have to really read all the words.
This does narrow the searches considerably.
Shifting gears, I want to
show you the last piece--
the second piece that's not
searched by that homepage bar.
And both of these, Chronicling America and
the World Digital Library which I'm going
to show you next are partnership
collections so they're part of us
but not part of us if that makes sense.
And I think that's why so far they're not
incorporated yet into that search box.
How many of you have seen
the world digital library?
Is this at all familiar?
No. No. Looks like a lot of no's.
Okay, I hope some of you get
as excited about this as I do.
The World Digital Library is a partnership
under the auspices of UNESCO led by the Library
of Congress with international institutions and
the goal of the World Digital Library is to try
to make available world treasures.
And each of these items is selected for its
value to the country that is presenting it
and each of these items comes
with considerable context.
Sounds like most of you are pretty
familiar with the Library of Congress
and so you know sometimes you get
a lot of information about an item,
and sometimes you get very
little information about an item.
The World Digital Library is different.
The World Digital Library comes
with considerable information.
This is what that page looks like.
You can see there's a whole
long paragraph of commentary.
I'm sure you can't read it on your screen but
you can see the bulk of it and the depths of it.
I'm going to hit some highlights of the WDL.
I'm going to invite you to explore on
your own-- again all of these pages are,
most of these pages are hyperlinked as
well-- and that'll be true in the recording.
If you look near the top of the
page you'll see the pink box
and that pink box says listen to this page.
All of these pages have audio casts attached
to them which I think are a fantastic support
for students who may struggle
decoding the written word.
They can take in the content but they
might struggle decoding the text.
And there's more.
These pages can also be translated into all
of the languages of the UN plus Portuguese.
Portuguese because Brazil was
an early strong partner in this.
So the objects themselves of course don't get
translated but the context around them does.
And so now here's the page in Arabic.
And you'll notice at the upper left that
same audio cast button that was on the page
to the right with a pink box around it is there.
So there's audio support in seven languages.
So I know several of you
said you were librarians.
You might share these with
your world language teachers.
If you're a classroom teacher, you might talk
to your world language teacher about ways
to get some cross-curricular work going on
to study the object as a historical object,
as a cultural artifact in some classes,
and to study the language in
the world language classes.
That wraps up the highlights
of what I want to show you.
If you're learning more about the WDL I will
point out that we had last year a whole session
on that presented by the folks who
work for the World Digital Library.
And I can't do justice to the zoom
capability through a series of screenshots
which is what I'm able to do here.
But I would encourage you--
go in, play around, explore.
There are many, many ways
to access that information.
More than I took the time to show
you because honestly I'm not sure
that there's anything less interesting than
watching somebody click through a screen
so I've really tried to streamline this for you.
But I want to leave you with this, I'm back
to the library's homepage and the pink boxes
at the top, I hope that you can read that it's
around a button that says ask a librarian.
The Library of Congress has
many, many librarians and many
of those librarians are available to help you.
So please use this service, clicking on that.
And it's at the top of most pages of the
Library of Congress will bring you to this page.
Thank you, I'm really glad to
see that you see value in it.
Susan and Bonnie talking about the value
of this to your language learner students.
Jennifer asks the excellent question of
is there a guided tour of the library?
The library has vast public museum space and
there are docent-led tours several times a day.
If you're bringing a group, there is a link
from the library's home page about visiting.
Clear up here at the top
you can see that it says--
put the green arrow in the right
place-- there's a link that, to visit.
And so if you're bringing a group, I forget
the number-- maybe it's either 10 or 20--
if you're bringing a largish
group I would advise you
to contact them in advance and arrange a tour.
Thanks Anne, but absolutely it's a
gorgeous, gorgeous, wonderful space
and I would encourage you to visit.
Jennifer as an individual you
can come join a public tour.
You can come wander around.
It's an amazing museum space that
doesn't get as much foot traffic as some
of the other beautiful museums in Washington,
D.C. I just want to point out before I forget
that I was on Ask a Librarian and I want
you to know that you can see the scope
of the experts available at the library
to help you find what you're looking for.
I direct your attention to
the pink bar at the bottom
of the page that's around
resources for teachers.
That comes into the office
where Anne and I and Kathy work.
It's staffed by our amazing colleague
Danna Bell who knows more about the library
than anybody I know, and
likes to teach about it.
So if you have a question, use this service.
Don't worry too much about directing
it to exactly the right place.
Make your best guess and the librarians
who field these questions know
each other and will forward them.
So if you send it to Dana and she
knows that somebody in another part
of the library is better qualified
to answer it, she'll forward it on
and that's true for the rest of them.